president biden gearing up for a supreme
court showdown after liberal justice
stephen breyer announced his retirement
earlier today
i will select the nominee
worthy of justice briar's legacy of
excellence and decency a person i will
nominate
will be someone with extraordinary
qualifications
character experience and integrity
and that person will be the first black
woman ever nominated to united states
supreme court
the president vowing to choose a nominee
by the end of february and now the fun
begins biden will be under enormous
pressure from the far left and the squad
over who will nominate making it very
likely he'll select the most radical
person for the job
and whoever he picks the ladies of the
view
they'd like to be consulted yes
this is happening in a time where we can
get another liberal and of course the
representation more than anything you
pointed out first black woman there's
only been two black men in it
that those numbers are a little shocking
and one doesn't really represent the
black community i always feel like that
particular branch of government is so
anti-democracy that somebody like amy
coney barrett uh was put in there
because she's a white woman yeah who
they say well she'll go against abortion
rights and she's a woman oh so that was
deliberate i think
dana perino i mean
where do i begin what does this mean the
woman thing
there's that you don't need to quote
that like that you can you can take that
one to the bank and also uh the the
attacks against claire installments
they're just so it's it's tired it's
lazy stop it with that because that's
annoying they hate a strong black man
they really do they must because i guess
that's you and strong black man and tim
scott yeah i think that what you'll see
is that this will be helpful to the to
biden for a bit right so it'll allow
them to focus the mind on something the
media will chase this for a while but
this this supreme court nomination is
likely to get done because they have the
votes for it but one thing it doesn't
just it won't do is it won't help solve
their problems on inflation crime uh the
border issues afghanistan continues that
isis is coming back all of these things
will continue and they will be there on
the other side of this uh
debate yeah because this doesn't really
swing the court i mean there's not a
huge national interest in how this is
gonna shake down yeah they're just gonna
break even that's all they're hoping for
but i just because they brought up uh
clarence thomas it's like when you're a
conservative black republican you really
gotta kick butt yeah right you got
there's no affirmative action for you
but here you know it's got to be awesome
to know you know you're being picked
because of your gender in race and
everybody knows that that's i mean we
talked about in the 8 block that there
was a lack of transparency there's no
lack of transparency here they're
telling you we are picking a female
black woman color and gender before
qualifications she may not even have to
be a judge she may not have to be a
lawyer but at least i mean that is
entirely wrong it's quotas but at least
it's transparent uh you know it's it's
like but the hypocrisy is they would
never use this kind of qualification if
their child was going into surgery you
know just as it's going under the knife
hold on a second i need to see the
gender identity the the race identity of
the operating room staff it has to be
exactly diverse before you operate on my
child no see this doesn't matter to them
so they can act like this is a
principled stance when it's not well
geraldo you brought this up the other
day do you think that by saying i'm only
going to nominate a black female is he s
discriminating against white males is
that what's going on here yes and white
females how dare he
there's no doubt the constitution is
being tested yes however it is a social
goal that i find appropriate it is true
that there's never been a black woman on
the high court i think it is past time
and the people that are being talked
about if if they pick from these top
three people these are fine justices
that have just been through this
grinding process because they're on the
federal appeals court so they've already
gone through it they've already been
tested they'll be fine he'll be fine and
i think that i go back to what i said
yesterday
this is an opportunity for republicans
to restore themselves as the gracious
party as the party of manners are
gracious
as the party
that puts country ahead of politics
whether that is true or not and and you
may be right on that judge still i think
it is an opportunity because as greg
said it's six three no matter what right
if they pick any of these liberals
they're gonna be six three it is six
three it's a wash so why be ill-mannered
why be gr aggressive why do
to this candidate what they did to
kavanaugh and uh i'll tell you why first
of all i agree with everyone at the
table there will be no ideological
change in the court it would be six
three now what they're looking for in
crazy maisie hirono says that she wants
a replacement to consider the impact and
the effects not just the law i mean you
now got these social justice warriors
coming in and they're gonna try to
educate the public in these public open
hearings that we want social justice we
want environmental justice forget about
the law just like all women need to be
believed i don't want them selling that
crap the supreme court is about law and
precedent the supreme court is and
should be pristine i have no problem
with ideological differences i have a
problem when people say i'm going to
decide based upon how this is going to
affect my town or you know how people
are going to see it who are my color or
the other color no the supreme court
votes on affirmative action it shouldn't
be made up of affirmative action i have
no problem with a female who's
african-american no problem i'm on tv
because of affirmative action but but
that's not the point she's got to do
you're on tv because of your mustache
she's got to be competent that's all we
want is competence
and that's all i have to say well that's
fine he will say
and we've seen these because we've
covered these she says crazy maisy
and you know what
did you coin that because that's a doozy
um but it's going to be theatrics
they're going to perform you're they're
going to read these things the staff
wrote them you know you want to do
booker uh what's booker gonna sound like
oh he's gonna be
i want to welcome you
to this uh a tremendous
ceremony and uh you look fantastic there
will be tears there will be tears
there's going to be someone will be long
profiles there's going to be long like
hour long prime time specials on the
background and you know what that'll be
great and then we can move on and they
can hear cases and one of those cases is
going to be affirmative action but you
know do you agree with me that the
republicans should go easy
no
i think that they should just on the
merits take it on the merits
i'm gracious in general you are yes you
are so long they were like filthy mouth
actually it's disgusting really you
could only hear from
up next the consequences of being soft
on crime why america is seeing a brutal
war on cops